all the time they spent together the man
and woman each maintained separate
residences in toronto throughout their
almost 15-year relationship
but during the summer months he was
hosting her at his two cottages in
muskoka her and her kids specifically
almost the entire summer during the
winter months from
thursdays to mondays they would fly down
to
um florida and they would stay down
there
often on his private jet so
there's quite an improvement in her
lifestyle meeting this guy at the
esso gas station when she managed to
score that date
even after dating his younger brother
anyway um
so the court examined the relationship
and assessed the credibility of both
eventually finding the man's credibility
was shakier than that of a woman
by the way the judge that ruled on this
was a female by the way
of example when shown a picture of him
and mrs clements okay so this is an
important
this is a really important one so but so
by way of an example so this is just one
example of literally
i'm gonna say not even dozens perhaps a
hundred
that are this damaging to his case of
we were not a uh not in a married
relationship
basically so when showing a picture of
him
and mrs clements in costa rica with the
words will you marry me written in the
sand
so you guys all know you know you'll see
it on social media all the time
uh the man and the woman sitting there
with the will you marry me
or costa rica you know 2011 you know
christmas 2011 or something like that
so in this case this dork writes will
you marry me in the sand
along with their names joined by a heart
he first denied promo proposing to her
suggesting the people sitting next to
them wrote the message in the sand not
him so this guy's
a bad liar in court because
it says will you marry me written in the
sand with their names joined by a heart
but he's but he's denying it so he's
he's going to lose massive credibility
here
uh you know step by step by step as he
goes
uh not him then he then he said he could
not recall and then he said if he did he
was not sure what the point was
so he keeps flip-flopping around
you